ja soweit Markus Söder der bayerische
Ministerpräsident mit der von allen mit
Spannung erwarteten Erklärung wie er
denn jetzt mit seinem Stellvertreter mit
Hubert Aiwanger von den Freien Wählern
verfährt Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer sie haben das gesehen er wird
nicht entlassen das hat Markus Söder
auch begründet er hat zwar gesagt dass
Hubert alwanger mit seinem Verhalten und
mit dem ganzen Sachverhalt Bayern
geschadet hat aber und seine Performance
das heißt also das was wie Hubert
Aiwanger mit diesen Vorwürfen in der
letzten Woche umgegangen ist alles
andere als glücklich war aber er hat
sich spät nicht zu spät zu Reue und
Distanzierung entschlossen er hat sich
entschuldigt das liegt auch kein Beweis
vor dass er dieses unsägliche Flugblatt
verfasst hat und das ganze ist auch 35
Jahre her und deswegen wäre eine
Entlastung eine Entlassung von Hubert
Aiwanger aus dem Amt des bayerischen
Wirtschaftsministers und
stellvertretenden Ministerpräsidenten
unverhältnismäßig wer sich ausdrückt hat
der bayerische Ministerpräsident hat
Hubert Aiwanger auch empfohlen zum
Beispiel das Gespräch mit jüdischen
Gemeinden zu suchen in dem Zusammenhang
ist viele auch der Name der Vorsitzenden
der jüdischen Gemeinde in München
Charlotte Knobloch und des Vorsitzenden
des Präsidenten des Zentralrats der
Juden in Deutschland Josef Schuster all
das was wir jetzt gerade gehört haben
das wollen wir noch einordnen mit einem
gesprächsgast der mir jetzt hoffentlich
zugeschaltet ist Albrecht von Lucke
Publizist und Journalist guten Morgen
kann man ja noch sagen davon Lucke was
ist ihre erste Einschätzung dieser
Erklärung von Markus Söder er entlässt
Hubert Aiwanger nicht er beläst ihn im
Amt er hat zwar schwere Fehler bei ihm
entdeckt und die auch klar benannt aber
er bleibt im Amt diese Entscheidung
nachvollziehbar ist sie durch den
Landtagswahl und den Landtagswahlkampf
vielleicht auch entscheiden mit
beeinflusst wie sehen Sie das
ja sie ist in meinen Augen in der Sache
durchaus überzeugend um nicht zu sagen
richtig aber natürlich all das ist auch
immer politisch mit motiviert um es am
Anfang zu Beginn ja ich finde es völlig
richtig fand die Argumentation von
Markus Söder auch stark er hat
tatsächlich einen durchaus sehr ernsten
abwägungsvorgang vorgezogen man sei ja
auch es war alles sehr genau schriftlich
notiert nicht die von Söder sonst in
freier Rede vorgetragen und die
Argumente sind in der Sache durchaus
überzeugend er musste immer abwägen
inwieweit auch vor allem eine Entlassung
von Herrn Aiwanger dazu geführt hätte
dass der Opfer Mythos an dem Herr
Aiwanger jetzt ja schon arbeitet weiter
zugeschlagen hätte es musste also ganz
enorme Gründe dafür geben ihn zu
entlassen die sind mit den starken
Argumenten dass es einerseits
tatsächlich 35 Jahre her ist dass er
einwanger sich auch Markus Söder hat das
sehr deutlich gesagt nach ausgesprochen
in Schwierigkeiten und es noch mal zu
wiederhole noch stärker zu machen nach
einer Phase in der er eher Zweifel in
seinem Verständnis der Angelegenheit hat
erzeugen müssen bzw erzeugt hat Herr
Aiwanger sich entschuldigt nach eben
geraumer Zeit großen
Anlaufschwierigkeiten wenn ich es so
salopp sagen darf aber dann kam die
Entschuldigung und der mitentscheidende
dritte Grund seit dieser Jugendzeit im
Alter von 16 Jahren ist vergleichbares
nicht passiert das heißt ja nicht dass
Aiwanger nicht durchaus
rechtspopulistisch die jüngsten Erding
aufgetreten wäre wo er durchaus sehr
afda ein populistischen Ton anschlägt
wir müssen uns die Demokratie
zurückholen das ist aber in der Sache
nicht vergleichbar mit diesem damaligen
Flugplatz der Umstand dass
Ellwanger auch reich war dass er gezeigt
hat dass er einsehen hat man wunderte
sich auch da ein Stück weit in der
Korrektur denn Markus Söder gab zu
verstehen dass er jetzt plötzlich
Ellwanger das zu einem ein zu einem ja
die sagte er zu einem einschneiden
Erlebnis erklärte das damalige Flugblatt
das Zeug ja immerhin im Nachhinein davon
dass er offensichtlich die schwere jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch oder nachdem er es
verdrängt hatte nachdem er sicherlich
auch erhoffte der
Buch würde an ihm vorbeigern dass er
jetzt die Dimension begriffen hat das
alles sind starke Gründe dafür ihm am
Arm zu lassen aber das ist natürlich
immer auch politisch hochgradig
motiviert Markus Söder so sehr das in
der Sache meines Erachtens richtig ist
weil man ansonsten Herrn Aiwanger und
den Freien Wählern eher den Opfermythos
zugespielt hätte und auch in der
Bevölkerung es nicht hätte recht
verständlich machen können das nachdem
er sich entschuldigt hat er entlassen
wird es ist natürlich Schwermut
politisch motiviert und das war für mein
Verständnis auch die schwächste Stelle
von Markus Söder er hatte es eigentlich
nicht nötig ja darf ich eine Nachfrage
stellen also sie hat gesagt
einerseitsreue und entschuldigung das
hatte er gezeigt am Donnerstag durch
diese Erklärung im gleichen Atemzug hat
er aber eine von einer Kampagne sogar
von einer Vernichtung seiner politischen
Existenz gesprochen wenn ein Politiker
so reagiert und zwei völlig
unterschiedliche Botschaften loslässt er
hat ja immerhin ein wichtiges Amt der
ist Parteivorsitzender in einer
zumindest in Bayern nicht gerade kleinen
Partei was hat das was macht das mit dem
politischen Verantwortungsbewusstsein
einer solchen Person nach außen hin
das ist natürlich auch eine Reaktion im
Übermaß gewesen und man wird sehen
Markus Söder hat es ja angedeutet
inwieweit her Aiwanger jetzt in der Lage
ist tatsächlich so etwas wie Reue zu
zeigen auch das Gespräch zu suchen das
sind ja gewissermaßen auch
Verpflichtungen auf die Zukunft die
jetzt eingegangen ist das war sicher
indiskutabel das war übrigens um es klar
zu sagen sofort die Instrumentalisierung
des Vorgangs durch Herrn Aiwanger man
wird also auch die nächsten großen
bierzeltauftritte die ja schon morgen
mit Killer muss beginnen werden von ihm
beobachten müssen um zu sehen ob er
wirklich begriffen hat und nicht wieder
instrumentalisiert aber man darf auch
eines nicht erkennen es ist ja
tatsächlich so dass das ist in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen ja auch zum
Ausdruck gekommen das ist tatsächlich
einige Menschen im Umfeld von einwanger
gab ein früherer Lehrer und andere die
dezidiert sehr gedrängt haben dass das
jetzt zum Vorschein kam manches ist in
der vorab Mitteilung er wäre der Autor
dieses Flugplatzes gewesen auch am Ende
nicht beweisbar gewesen das war ja mit
der entscheidende Punkt auf den Markus
Söder abstellte ein Beweis nicht
erbracht worden kann wahrscheinlich auch
gar nicht mehr erbracht werden der
einzige der ist vielleicht anders
artikulieren könnte wäre der Bruder
Helmut Aiwanger der sich ja jetzt zum
Verfasser ausgegeben hat also wir sagen
in der Sache sind das meines Erachtens
nicht die entscheidenden Gründe die
hätten dazu führen dürfen ihn zu
entlassen aber was Markus Söder finde
ich im Überschwang und da kam dann sein
eigenes politisches Interesse
ausgesprochen zum Ausdruck dann wieder
deutlich machte es wird keine
schwarz-grüne Koalition in Bayern geben
das ist der eigentliche Kardinal
strategische Grund den er hat er wollte
natürlich einwanger auch unbedingt in
seinem Team halten um die angeblich
bürgerliche Koalition man muss den
bürgerlichkeitsbegriff natürlich jetzt
schon ob das Rechtspopulismus von Herrn
Lange ein Stück weit in Frage stellen
aber er hält natürlich unbedingt an
dieser Koalition fest weil er ansonsten
sein ganzes waldstrategisches Konzept
umwerfen müsste und das hat er noch
einmal wie ich bin ganz kurz nachfragen
es ging ja nicht nur darum ob Hubert
Aiwanger die Kurve gekriegt sondern ob
auch Markus Söder die Kurve das haben
sie jetzt gerade ange deutet mit den
Koalitionsfragen wenn es nicht doch eine
große Überraschung passiert dann wird es
wahrscheinlich nach den Landtagswahlen
auch für eine Mehrheit reichen aus CSU
und Freien Wähler eine Fortsetzung
dieser Koalition kann wieder einfach
nach dieser Vorgeschichte so
weitermachen wird bleiben wie geht's
Söder damit um wie wird auch die CSU mit
den Freien Wählern in Zukunft nach der
Landtagswahl zusammenarbeiten können
naja gucken wir uns die CSU an die ist
bekanntlich eine machtmaschine und in
der Tat Markus Söder hat sich jetzt
derartig auf die Fortsetzung dieser
Koalition fort festgelegt und wenn er
auf der
causaiwanger jetzt nicht andere Dingen
noch mal einschlagen und nicht deutlich
würde man kann ja übrigens auch gespannt
sein wie wir und das wird jetzt ja
werden sich viele Journalisten über die
Beantwortung der Fragen beugen wie das
ausgeht aber wenn nichts weiteres
auftaucht hat sich Markus Söder Kardinal
darauf festgelegt dass diese angeblich
bürgerliche Koalition fortgesetzt wird
und das halte ich schon wieder
seinerseits für eine erstaunliche
Abwertung einer schwarz-grünen Koalition
man muss sich schon sehr wundern das was
beispielsweise in Nordrhein-Westfalen
offensichtlich mit Herrn wüst und einer
grünen Partei gut gelingt was übrigens
auch einer Voraussicht nach nach der
nächsten Bundestagswahl der Fall sein
würde nämlich Markus Söder wenn ihr dann
übrigens Kanzlerkandidat würde was er
meines Erachtens durchaus weiter im
Schilde führt dann müsste es schwarz
grün sein dass er sich so Kardinal auf
diese Freien Wähler festlegt und
gewissermaßen die Grünen erklärt und
eine schwarz-grüne Koalition vorab
verdammt das ist schon erstaunlich das
zeigt wie sehr natürlich auch dieses
belassen von Aiwanger im Amt auch
parteistrategisch motiviert ist er will
auf Gedeih und Verderb an dieser
Koalition festhalten weil er weiß sonst
würde sein ganzes Konzept fallen er hat
sich auf die Grünen regelrecht
eingeschossen und das ist dann schon
politisch ausgesprochen fragwürdig wenn
er einerseits eine causereianger ich
meine ja durchaus mit richtigen
Argumenten nicht zum Rücktritt fahren
lassen sieht aber trotzdem nachdem er so
groß die Schwierigkeit mit Aiwanger ja
doch deutlich gemacht hat indem er sich
dann so an ihn fesselt das ist
parteistrategie das ist aber aus
startsaison oder auch aus bayerischer
Saison nicht recht nachvollziehbar und
das macht meines Erachtens die Schwäche
seiner Argumentation aus er von Luke wir
wollen vielleicht noch ein Schutz
zurückgehen und nochmal genau schauen
was hat eigentlich jetzt zu dieser
Entscheidung gefühlt ein wesentlicher
Grund war ja offensichtlich nicht nur
die Beantwortung der 25 Fragen die jetzt
Markus Söder offensichtlich ja
ausgereicht hat sondern auch die
Erklärung von Donnerstag wir sind da
gerade ja selbst schon drauf eingegangen
wir zeigen noch mal diese kurze
Erklärung Hubert Aiwanger am Donnerstag
in der Bayerischen
Wirtschaftsministerium wo er sich zum
ersten Mal dezidiert zu den Vorwürfen
äußert hat und auch sich entschuldigt
hat und auch Reue gezeigt hat
in den vergangenen Tagen hat es
zahlreiche Vorwürfe gegen mich gegeben
es geht um ein abscheuliches Pamphlet
das vor 36 Jahren in meiner Schultasche
gefunden wurde und es sind Aussagen
aufgetaucht die den Eindruck vermitteln
ich werde es Jugendlicher auf einen
menschenfeindlichen Weg geraten ich habe
als jugendlich auch Fehler gemacht ich
bereue zutiefst wenn ich durch mein
Verhalten in Bezug auf das in Rede
stehende Pamphlet oder weitere Vorwürfe
gegen mich aus der Jugendzeit Gefühle
verletzt habe meine aufrichtige
Entschuldigung gilt so vor dass da ein
Opfern des in es Regimes deren
Hinterbliebenen und allen Beteiligten
und der wertvollen Erinnerungsarbeit
die genannten Vorwürfe liegen 36 Jahre
zurück ich betone nochmals ich habe das
beim Fleet nicht verfasst ich
distanziere mich in jeder Form von dem
ekelhaften Inhalt ich war nie ein
Antisemit ich war nie ein
menschenvereint
die Vorwürfe haben mich erschreckt ich
kann mich nicht erinnern jemals einen
Hitlergruß gezeigt zu haben ich habe
keine Hitler reden vor dem Spiegel
einstudiert weitere Vorwürfe wie
menschenfeindliche Witze kann ich aus
meiner Erinnerung wieder vollständig
dementieren noch bestätigen sollte dies
geschehen sein so entschuldige ich mich
dafür in aller Form es ist jedoch nicht
akzeptabel dass diese Verfehlungen jetzt
in einer politischen Kampagne gegen mich
und meine parteiinstrumentalisiert
werden ich habe den Eindruck ich soll
politisch und persönlich fertig gemacht
werden es ist ein negatives Bild von mir
in den letzten Tagen gezeichnet worden
das bin nicht ich das ist nicht Hubert
wie gesagt diese Erklärung von Hubert
Aiwanger hat möglicherweise mit dazu
beigetragen dass Markus Söder ihn jetzt
auch im Amt des bayerischen
Wirtschaftsministers beläst und auch
seine Stellvertreters das haben wir
gerade gehört es geht ja auch noch darum
dass jetzt Markus Söder hat das
angekündigt die 25 Fragen die er ihm
gestellt hat zu diesem Vorgang um dieses
unsägliche Flugblatt ja veröffentlicht
werden soll einschließlich der Antworten
von Hubert Aiwanger die sollen also auch
mit seiner Zustimmung wird das
veröffentlicht jetzt im Anschluss
unmittelbar nach dieser Pressekonferenz
es wird auch ins Internet gestellt also
ist dort auch einsehbar Albrecht von
Lucke ist uns immer noch zugeschaltet ja
wenn Luke wir haben ja schon gerade über
das Verhalten gesprochen von Hubert
eiwanger einerseits Reue zeigen anders
als Angriff auf Medien und politische
Gegner haben Sie eine Vorstellung wie
das jetzt den Wahlkampf in Bayern bis
zum achten Oktober noch beeinflussen
wird
ja das ist die ganz große Frage das was
Markus Söder Herrn Aiwanger ja ein
bisschen in Stammbuch geschrieben hat
oder ihn zur Auflage sagen wir es mal so
gemacht hat war das er diese Reue auch
zum Ausdruck bringt und da wird ganz
entscheidend sein ob Aiwanger diesen
Vorwurf der Kampagne der
Instrumentalisierung weiter aufrecht
erhält natürlich wird es so sein müssen
wir uns doch nicht vormachen dass
nachdem diese 25 Fragen und Antworten
publiziert werden natürlich eine hitzige
Debatte oder zumindest eine Debatte
einsetzen wird über die Frage hätte
Söder eiwanger entlassen müssen das ist
normal das ist ein journalistischen
Betrieb auch richtig aber ich vermute
ich finde durchaus ja aus richtigen
Gründen hat sich so oder so entschieden
dann könnte diese Debatte abkriegen und
dann wird man sehen ob Hubert ein lange
davon Abstand nimmt die
Instrumentalisierung zu betreiben das
war natürlich sofort der Versuch
gewissermaßen die opferfrage umzudrehen
sich selber zum Opfer deklar zu
deklarieren das ist natürlich ein
Phänomen wie wir es von Populisten
durchaus kennen Donald Trump als
Speerspitze da wird man also Hubert
Albaner durchaus überprüfen können ob er
die Einsicht hat es nicht auszuspielen
die Versuchung ist für ihn immer da das
wird aber ein Stück weit auch davon
abhängen ob es eine gewisse Beruhigung
in der Causa Albaner gibt und ob er dann
vielleicht tatsächlich selber das
Einsehen hat
gut die es wird in den bayerischen
Bierzelten mutmaßlich jetzt bis zum 8
oktober bei den Wahlkampfveranstaltungen
keinen
Temperaturabfall geben also von locker
letzte Frage zum Thema sie haben es
gerade auch schon angesprochen was die
koalitionsstrategie angeht dass ich
Markus Söder ja jetzt mehrere minder auf
gedeiht und Verderb mit dem
Koalitionspartner zusammen tut den
Freien Wählern obwohl es ja vor einigen
Jahren mal so aussah als gäbe auch
schwarz grün möglich er gilt ja als
durchaus geschmeidig der bayerische
Ministerpräsident war so klug sich diese
Strategie jetzt damit irgendwie zu
nehmen da auch auszuwählen denn das
könnte er mutmaßlich nach dem 8 Oktober
sich auch andere Koalitionspartner
auszusuchen beziehungsweise anzusprechen
und vielleicht den einen auch gegen den
anderen auszuspielen
ja absolut insofern sehe ich die
politische Klugheit genau in der letzten
Entscheidung der totalen Absage an
Schwarz-Grün die man ja eigentlich auch
als eine begreifen muss die weit über
den Wahltag hinausgeht als eine nicht
kluge Entscheidung an Markus Söder hat
sich damit ungemein an Aiwanger
gefesselt er ist gewissermaßen nicht
gleich in Geiselhaft aber ist eben sehr
darauf angewiesen dass soweit einwanger
sich jetzt auch so verhält wie er es ihm
nahegelegt hat und das auch keine neuen
Vorfälle aufkommen aber eines will ich
noch dazu sagen es gibt durchaus die
Hoffnung und deswegen bleibt die
Entscheidung ja richtig es gibt die
Hoffnung dass die Sache ein wenig
jedenfalls jetzt anders verläuft das
müssen wir uns alternativ denken als sie
verlaufen wäre wenn Markus Söder
Aiwanger entlassen hätte machen wir uns
das einmal bewusst dann wäre Aiwanger
mit den Freien Wählern immer und in
jedem Fall mit dem absoluten Opfer
Mythos durch die Bierzelte gezogen es
hätte ein ungeheuren backlash gegeben äh
das jetzt erst recht der Mann ist
weggeputzt das wäre der schallende Ruf
vieler gewesen und der
volkstribuniwanger hätte das mit
Sicherheit massiv ausgespielt das müssen
wir uns schon bewusst machen insofern
trägt diese Entscheidung ihm an zu
lassen durchaus dazu bei die Lage nicht
weiter zu eskalieren das war natürlich
auch die allergrößte Angst von Markus
Söder dass ihm viele von der Fahne
gegangen gewesen wären möglicherweise
wenn er sich anders entschieden hätten
und umso mehr die Freien Wähler gewählt
hätten die ja sowieso bereits mächtig
sind
jetzt eine Schalter die wir noch nach
München geplant haben kommt leider nicht
zustande zu einer Kollegin vom
Bayerischen Rundfunk deswegen bitte ich
Sie also von Luke noch einen Moment
sitzen zu bleiben sie haben es jetzt
auch gerade noch mal bei Aiwanger gesagt
es geht ja auch um Populismus also in
dem Fall um Rechtspopulismus er hat ja
auch sehr kritikwirbelige Äußerungen
gemacht neulich in Erding dass ich die
schweigende Mehrheit die Demokratie
zurückholen soll so als würden wir in
einer Diktatur leben das hat ja auch
Markus Söder massiv kritisiert was
bedeutet denn jetzt diese dieser Fall
diese Affäre diese Diskussion um Hubert
einwanger für die weitere Entwicklung
des politischen Populismus in
Deutschland das ist ja etwas was uns
sehr bedrängt auch in Bezug auf noch
eine andere Partei auch die
bevorstehenden Wahl vor allem im
nächsten Jahr in Ostdeutschland wie wer
hat daraus Vorteile aus dieser
Diskussion aus diesen Verwerfungen aus
diesen Konflikten um Hubert Albaner
ja sie deuten es ja wunderbar an
natürlich ist es ein Stück weit auch die
AFD die mit dem heutigen Tage
triumphiert denn natürlich ist der Grad
zwischen dem was Aiwanger gesagt hat
wir müssen uns die Demokratie die
schweigende Mehrheit muss sich die
Demokratie zurückholen und müssen den in
Berlin dann mal ganz deutlich sagen
halt's Maul das ist natürlich ein Jargon
den man ansonsten von der AFD kennt und
viele werden natürlich Herr höcke dürfte
in Kürze jedenfalls darauf zurückkommen
darauf verweisen dass ein Mann mit
dieser Aussage und natürlich mit diesem
Flugplatz in Bayern weiter
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
bleiben kann das ist die Hypothek
natürlich und das macht es für die AFD
recht leicht diese Aktion und diese
Geschichte auszuschlachten das ist das
große Dilemma damit hat natürlich zu
allererst Hubert einwanger die Lage der
Demokratie nicht einfacher gemacht
das heißt also wir werden in diesem
Umgang mit Iberger vielleicht kann es
auch anders formulieren was müssen denn
zum Beispiel die Medien lernen aus
diesem Umgang mit Hubert Aiwanger und
dem was an Vorwürfen da war was nicht
bewiesen werden konnte jedenfalls nicht
in den wesentlichen Punkten was sollten
die Medien aus dieser aus dieser
Diskussion dieser Affäre um Hubert
Aiwanger lernen ja unbedingt man kann
eines zuallererst lernen eine
Instrumentalisierung die Herr Aiwanger
jetzt ja getätigt hat wir haben die
Äußerung gehört und bei den fraglich ist
ob es nicht weiter tun wird wird
natürlich ungemein erleichtert wenn ein
solcher Vorfeld ungemein im Vorfeld
einer Wahl einer so entscheidenden
Landtagswahl
publik wird das hätte man natürlich
vermeiden können wenn man es zu einem
weit früheren Zeitpunkt publik gemacht
hätte beispielsweise ein oder zwei Jahre
vor der Wahl das ist ja kein ganz neues
Phänomen man weiß von dieser Seite lang
bzw sie schwirrte immer im Raum das
heißt das ist ein Vorwurf und man wird
auch sagen müssen es ist
schwierig wenn die
flugblattgeschichte das flugbad sehr
stark doch mit dem mit der mit der
Aussage schwanger ging es ist von
Aiwanger verfasst ich falte es nicht für
glaubhaft oder für zumindest zweifelhaft
dass Herr Aiwanger nicht möglicherweise
eben doch der Verfasser gewesen ist weil
ein Äußerungen zufolge eher weit
rechtsradikaler in den in seiner
Jugendzeit war als sein Bruder Helmut
der offensichtlich eher links und Rock
n' Roll mit langen Haaren orientiert war
aber es geht eben die alte Aussage der
Unschuldsvermutung solange ein Beweis
nicht erbracht werden kann ist es
ausgesprochen schwierig jemanden
aufgrund von Anhaltspunkten an einer
solchen in einer solchen cause zu
kriegen beziehungsweise ihm das Handwerk
wenn ich das mal potentiert sagen
politisch zu leben beziehungsweise ihn
auch nur zu überführen das ist alles
nicht gelungen deswegen traf Markus
Söder meines Erachtens aus den richtigen
sachlichen Gründen diese Entscheidung
und das hat es dann einfacher auch recht
leicht gemacht das bisher zu
instrumentalisieren und wird ihm auch
weiter die Möglichkeit geben es weiter
zu instrumentalisieren auch so da ist
schon wir müssen leider zu Ende vielen
Dank Albrecht Publizist und Journalist
Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer das
war aus aktuellen Anlass der
die Pressekonferenz die Erklärung von
Markus Söder zur nicht Entlassung von
Hubert aiwang er bleibt im Amt sie
können ab jetzt im Internet nachlesen
welche Fragen würde Albaner gestellt hat
welche Antworten eiwanger hast du wieder
gegeben hat das war's hier mit der
Phönix vor Ort aus aktuellen Anlass
jetzt kommt Phoenix persönlich dass ich
ihn besonders ans Herz legen möchte Eva
Lindenau interviewt Carlo Masala von der
Universität der Bundeswehr in München es
geht natürlich um die deutsche
politische Strategie im Krieg gegen die
Ukraine eine spannende Angelegenheit
bleiben sie bei Phoenix